hi peter king looking ahead at the wild
card weekend
and of the six matchups
the one that i think is going to be
toughest for the underdog team and the
road team is the chicago bears going
into new orleans
now you might say well of course it's
going to be tough drew brees
uh
alvin kumar alvin kamara coming back
maybe even michael thomas coming back of
course it's going to be hard for the
bears but i think there are two hopes
that the chicago bears have
uh in this game number one is
feed david montgomery he got hot near
the end of the year finished with 1070
yards after in mid-season basically
being a non-factor so i think they've
got to feed
david montgomery
uh consistently throughout this game i
think that's number one number two
put mitchell trubisky in manageable
situations
and so what i mean is if it's third and
long you know what do a pitch out you
know do a reverse do something like that
don't force mitchell trubisky into
situations that have given him trouble
in the past look trubisky has had a good
uh last four to five weeks of the season
he was exposed against a good defense
with the green bay packers on sunday and
that's why i say it's so important to
have david montgomery have a very big
game in this game and lastly i'm
reminded of something that bill parcells
once said to the offensive coordinator
of the new york giants when they were
really out gunned personnel wise before
going into the super bowl against
buffalo three decades ago
and parcell said to ron earhardt play
clock ball
in other words
don't try to be explosive and be huge on
first and second down and be throwing
the ball all over the place get the ball
in manageable situations run it
keep the clock moving you know if i were
matt nagy i'm telling all my receivers
i'm telling alan robinson jimmy graham
you know what even if it costs you a
couple of yards stay in bounds do not go
out of bounds and so i think those are
the kind of things that the bears have
to be thinking about
only give the saints maybe nine or ten
possessions in this game
and make sure that david robinson has a
lot of chances to bleed the clock in new
orleans on sunday
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports